my so so I have some things that I
wanted to talk about but I wanted to
know if any of you had something any
questions or something that you guys
wanted to to talk about this one I have
a poll from last month yeah told me
about a video by David Burns the art
where other if you remember he mentioned
and psychism and also work saw other
modern theories of mind and yeah you
asked me if I had watched it but nah I
haven't watched it that I did if you
still want to talk about it yeah sure
let's go it's definitely worth it I mean
definitely heart is very very smart very
annoying with very smart and so so it's
it's definitely worth watching because
he's writing a book on consciousness
which i think is going to be I wrote to
John reveille key by the way and I asked
him to watch the the video and he said
that he's read all of David Bentley
hearts maybe not all but he said he's
read quite a few of David Bentley hearts
books and he that he really appreciates
him so so I told him to watch that that
talk and he yeah he also enjoyed he also
enjoyed that talk as well uh I
there's you especially mentioned that
video to me last time because he talked
about 10sec ism at some point to the
talk and I think I actually agree with
him and I think even Bergson would agree
with him there's a small subtle thing he
said that he disagrees with a
materialist or naturalist and psychic
isms right
he is quite sympathetic to a
supernaturalists penstock isms and
Bergson would fall on that camp there's
I mean there's there's a risk in what
I'm gonna say right now that I could go
on the attendant and Lewis your
interests but so I think I should start
by asking you a question first
um you know the we all find you
interesting Gentiles don't worry it's
hard when you're too deep into your own
plus clothes because the reason you
don't know if anybody else cares because
you listen to other flows the person you
don't care about what they say so yeah
anyway so I just wanted to ask you up
that's it uh okay yeah before I before I
even try to make my point I'm gonna ask
you one question that doesn't seem
related but trust me it is so let's say
you're a materialist you're you have a
basic idea that let's say those
fundamental particles of physics they
follow certain laws and when they get
jumbled up together they follow some
laws again it's just that the
interaction gets flick it and in theory
you could you know compute the results
of all those interactions and you know
because of quantum stuff you would have
to use probabilities you cannot really
predict exactly what would happen but
you know if in theory I could know all
the positions and velocities of the
particles in my body I could use some
really complicated computer to figure
out what all the the atoms molecules
cells organs and ultimately what my old
body would do even as I altered these
words right now I could you know
completely explain that materialistic
that's the that is the crux of the
materialist explanation and even if I
say you want to add consciousness
somewhere in that that worldview the
thing is you know even if more like like
David Bentley or not mentioned in his
talkin that's pretty much the state of
philosophy of man right now most people
agree that you know in that story I told
you at some point you will have to make
place for for consciousness and it's not
identical to whatever I just talked
about there's something more than just
mechanical causes that's going on with
us but the issue is that you know the
story I just told you seems complete you
know there's no all of the causality
that old story is so so complete so
exhaustive at least in theory it should
explain everything I do physically you
know so there is no real room for my
consciousness to act as even as I say
these words right now the women my mouth
moves the way my man
kids in and out as I breathe in and out
of these words in theory I could explain
that mechanistically according to the
materials and what what I would like to
ask you and what you know I think there
are pencil I think then sigh kiss like
Berkshire that is supernaturalists I
kissed if you want to use david anthony
rizzo terminology the supernatural sense
I kissed can address the question I just
asked you but I haven't really heard
anybody else says any answer so what I
want to know is you know in that pool
make Anna stick story I just told you
there's a point where you know
consciousness happens and there's
something that actually no breaks in the
material story there's there's something
that actually breaks in the story and I
want to know where according to you
where do you think the problem is okay
so this is going to I don't know if this
is going to answer your question but
when I hear your question my first
intuition is to say the problem arises
at at each of those on each of the steps
where there's an identity at every place
in that in the in the process that you
described where you jump from
multiplicity to unity there's a problem
at all those steps so when you when you
go from the quantum you know whatever
field or whatever of potentiality of
possibility when you go from like you
said you have to use probability at that
stage when you go from there to the
actual particles when you go from the
particles to the atoms when you jump
from the atoms to the molecules when you
jump from the molecules etc etc and then
when you jump to you speaking breathing
all those identities all those all those
things that have oneness to them I think
that that's the that's the problem of
the mechanistic
of the mechanistic description is that
is what they call what do they call
emergence I love I love what David
Bentley heart says in that quote he says
emergence is just the the word they used
to replace magic it's like they just use
a word to replace a process which they
absolutely do not understand
which is how things you know become one
and and and so they just used that word
to replace what what other people would
use to be magic and so I think that
that's the problem the problem happens
the problem happens in the play in the
manner in which things become one and
then the Christian response to that is
that's what logos that's what logos is
that's what especially in st. Maximus
the Confessor he really does it have
this idea that logos is mmm you know the
the the the identity the essence the
purpose all those things kind of wrapped
into one of what makes something
something basically and so I think that
does that do you think that that does
that answer the question you're asking I
think I agree and I think Burke sons
would agree as well I want to try to
push you further on one point let's say
when you jump from one world to another
let's say from atoms to molecules or
from maybe molecules to cells and at
some point do you think that you know
it's not just the reason what one of the
reasons why you can't do that jump that
the identity is because you actually
cannot predict what will happen so let's
see if I try to predict your behavior
Jonathan looking at the behavior of all
of your cells
I would actually not be able to do so so
maybe I would get a that's something
that Bergson thought and what it's
something that supernaturalists like
it's a it's a you know even if in theory
I could let's say know all of the the
positions and velocities of the
particles in your brain let's say and if
I try to you know compute what you would
do at this moment or if I could
replicate the experiment what you would
do in such a stress situation over the
next thousand iterations let's say you
know the materials would want to say
that I can predict the you know the all
the the probability distribution that
would occur and is to
naturelle psychics would say that no
actually you could not you know if if I
say I told you the prompted distribution
ahead of time I say you could always
decide to break it you do not have to
follow those laws so it would be
unpredictable that's something you would
endorse I've never thought I've never
thought about that and I don't know like
in terms of the technical aspects of it
I wouldn't know like I would I wouldn't
know ya know when you say when you say
it it's it sounds reasonable to me in
terms of in terms of understanding how
in every single occasion any unity is
more than its parts like I need any form
of unity is always more than the parts
that constitute it you know there's
something there's some animating
principle there's some there's a logos
there's a name there's an identity which
which makes something into into one and
that cannot be reduced to its to its
elemental to the particles that make it
and so in that sense I would I
intuitively I would agree with you but I
it's hard for me to know because I like
that those types of the type of
experiment where I would know if you
could predict my behavior with all those
calculations I I don't know I'm not I'm
not enough of a scientist to answer that
question but in principle I think that
that it's that it's always true that a
whole is more than its parts that's for
sure cool
yeah that this is the modern way to talk
about free will because things get
complicated now because of probabilities
we know from physics but you know don't
wait to ask if we have Frugal or not you
know is to ask if the probability
distributions given given to us by
physics fail when we make choices right
okay yeah so man I was just asking it in
a very complicated way whether or not
you think we have free will by breaking
the implications right I do I've to
admit that I've never thought about it
I've never thought I've never thought
about the the relationship between
freedom and and let's say the break
between the different the different
levels matters a lot that's the point
where a lot of mother and son I think
that's the biggest problem that mother
depends I guess
the materialist there were none super
naturalist ones you know they have to
explain no that's something David
Merrick mentioned in a stock you know
let's say you're on you your materialist
and you learn about consciousness one
day and you analyze all them my theory
doesn't work I have to put consciousness
back into the world so like a lot of
materialists are doing right now he
becomes a pen scientist and he says well
if consciousness has to happen in the
brain then we must somehow be present in
the cells in the molecules in the atoms
and particles so you put consciousness
back all the way to the bottom right
yeah but then the question is you know
how do those combine why do the
consciousness of the fundamental
particles combine yeah and you know how
can it ever especially you know that's
that's a tough point that Bergson talked
about this but here if you it's like
it's talk about this right now
at least for now it's a if you have the
the all mechanistic causal story I just
told you about and let's say you put
even if you do put consciousnesses into
the funny little particles well you can
it seems that you have the whole story
that you know you can explain everything
that happens mechanistically using you
know your particles atoms molecules and
so on that story you can put
consciousness into the particles but why
would there be consciousness in the
atoms and the molecules and the cells
and so on and even if you know that it's
somehow combined why would it combine
into something coherent yeah well yeah
yeah I think that I'm for sure I think
that the Christian answer the the st.
Maximus answer is is the is the primacy
of the human person in the sense that it
is you know st. max we talked about how
the human the person the human being is
the laboratory of the union of all
opposites and so the vve to a certain
extent the the unity of things appears
through human consciousness now whether
or not whether or not there's
consciousness in the
actual things I don't think that I think
that that might be a way to get around
the the special the special place that
they that humanity plays let's say in in
this whole story in the cosmos which in
the in Christianity is definitely a
central space in a certain manner the it
really is clear that human beings
participate in in creation and
participate even to a certain extent in
the manner in which the world exists we
and so I think that if you see it to me
that seems to be the solution to the
problem is that is that through through
human consciousness then that's how
those that's how those levels exist it
doesn't mean it's a relative thing it
doesn't mean that it's a subjective
thing at all it did say it's a universal
it's universal but it's contained in in
it's contained in the human experience
it's containing human nature so because
in the story I just told you the
advantage that super naturalist since I
guess is that by saying that once or
even following what you did which you
said earlier about the logos let's say
when you have one level one multiplicity
that becomes United in in one of those
then you know the unity can you break
the causal predictions of the lower
level it can do things that do not yeah
explains why the ion would evolve as
well so this way you can explain why our
consciousness you know is coherent why
it has a wait wait wait wait has wrong
logos instead of being just a jumbled
mess of other consciousnesses of
fundamental particles we think that's
which is the efendim yeah exactly right
no but for sure I mean I think that the
idea of logos in the world is that is
logos in a certain manner is also is
present in every aspect of reality of
course it doesn't necessarily mean that
you have to you know the Logie are in a
way this is the way I understand it the
Logie are indefinite it's not like
there's a definite amount of loci there
there's an indefinite amount of loci
which become contained in higher higher
Logie so you know it's like you know I
always use the example the microphone
microphone has an indefinite amount of
Logie and those are contained in the
logos of the microphone and then you
know then you can keep going up until
you reach you know the there's a human
human consciousness human capacity human
human mind and then those human minds
also come together and then are kind of
an offering up to to the divine mind
which is which transcends all the all
everything and so that's kind of this
that that movement of everything
gathered the human being really is a
central figure that's why this whole
idea of the human being as a microcosm
you know you see that in so many you've
seen in same access but you see it in
Renaissance thinking and in medieval
thinking it really is this eye not only
the idea that the human being is a let's
say a little version of the cosmos but
that he gathers the cosmos was within
himself is also part of being a
microcosm and so on so that's kind of
how to me that's that's how I solved
those problems is is to see the central
importance of the human person and then
to understand this multiplicity as as as
coming together within all the you know
in a hierarchy up to you know our own
person and then together in communion up
towards the transcendent problem really
deep problems talking about combination
of different consciousness is probably
because you know we still seem to have a
very Cartesian idea of what a
consciousness is something there eat
them you know yeah and not extended and
you know separate like yeah I think your
Center video is really great I think
that using the word love is just too
sappy they don't want to use the word
love because that's it that's the key
that's that's love is the is the key to
everything you know and that's that's
the Christian answer is that that that
the world exists through love and God is
love and God and love is that that
possibility for things to be in
communion and one and multiple at the
same time and that goes all the way up
into the the Trinity as the is the
transcendent example of that that
since in love so no it's not love
doesn't sound like like like an
analytical word and yeah go back to
evolution do you you know because I
explained that in scientists at least
like Braxton can give an idea of why
consciousness would evolve and on your
side how do you do you try to explain it
and if you do you know do you go along
broadly pictures in your minds I guess
or just I don't know I don't I don't
like I don't mind
Jordans the way that he describes things
I definitely don't care very much I
don't think I don't you know it's funny
cuz I remember when I was in angelical
people would you know they'd always want
to know if you're a creationist you're a
creationist and you know when I was a
teenager I actually was a creationist
for a little while just cuz everybody
around me was a creationist and then
when I started to understand
evolutionary theory and started to
understand those ideas I thought well
these aren't silly like there's some
interesting things in there and then I
started to pay attention and found it
interesting and then when I mostly
discovered a non-scientific vision of
the world a symbolic vision of the world
then it started not to matter to me and
so people would ask me you know do you
believe in evolution and my answer is
always I don't believe in evolution I
think it happened but I don't believe in
it like I don't I don't don't think
about it I don't trust it i don't I
don't put my trust in evolution I don't
bother me that it that things
mechanically happened that way but it I
definitely don't I don't I didn't seem
to me like that's the best structure to
know how we should live today and how we
should be together and how we should
live in in communion I think the phenom
phenomenal logical approach to to to to
the way we experience the world to
phenomena I think is far more useful in
order to describe how we actually exist
in the world and I also think that that
you know the religious structures and
the religious symbolic structures
are far more useful to help us
understand the purpose of existence and
so because of that you know until today
I usually don't and and then so when I
heard Jordan talk about evolution the
way talked about it I thought it was
interesting because I thought oh it's
interesting because he he's able to talk
about it
in a manner which takes into let's say
takes into okay so this is I guess this
is oh this is a way I think I mentioned
as before in one of the Q&A is is that
the interesting thing that's happening
and which I do find interesting is that
as let's say science has taken over the
entire it has taken over the entire
field of a perception let's say in in
the new atheist types where it's like
science is everything scientific
knowledge is everything and then we even
have you know now like this this whole
science of consciousness and and all of
that and and that's what Jordan uses
often to describe some of the things
he's describing then what happens is
there no law they can no longer pretend
like they're an absolute opposition to
religious thinking because you know the
whole enlightenment was done in
opposition was done in like we're gonna
get rid of this dark horrible thing
that's religion and we're going to
replace it with reason and with science
and with all this and so that kind of
march of progress and march of thinking
now it's over it's like okay so now you
you can't oh you've taken over the
entire field and so now you actually now
have to explain religion it has to fit
in your model or else if you doesn't fit
in your model there's something missing
there's something missing in your model
you you've opposed it to build your to
put your model in front but now you have
to to to include you have to include
that which you fought if you want your
model to be all encompassing and in
doing that where that's where we're
seeing this strange flip where all of a
sudden it's like oh wait a minute
things are now flipping back where we're
realizing the the supremacy of
consciousness and the inevitability of
hierarchies of meaning all these things
are now appearing even in the eyes of
the scientist john reveille is of course
a perfect example of that
and so it's an interest to me that
I find very interesting so that's one of
the reasons why I pay attention to this
to this whole thing that's going on with
you with Jordan and with John reveille
Qian and with other and the discussion
with other people who are talking and
what's the name of the other guy they're
the the consciousness guy forget his
name again we talked about him quite so
many times we often there you go that
guy Saturday so that's what I find
that's definitely something that I find
very interesting and I think it's that
it's it's really that which has made me
all of a sudden pay attention to to
science more because you know because uh
because I think that there's an
interesting thing happening right now
and and and it's worth paying attention
to and it's worth speaking into it and I
think that if you notice the way that I
speak I think that I've adjusted the way
that I speak to people and I've adjusted
the way that I give my talks some not
always but sometimes I've adjusted them
to talk to those people to talk to the
people who are kind of realizing this
shift that's going on right now and this
kind of this flip and so to be able to
speak into it in a manner that they'll
understand all those talk that I did you
know like sacred art in secular terms
and in sacred space in secular terms is
it's pretty much addressed to those
people addressed to those people who are
suddenly realizing that you you no
longer can't avoid hierarchies of
meaning and you can't avoid you know
consciousness as at least the question
to be answered you know to be talked to
be to be discussed you know so so yeah
so so I think so I think that that's
that's a that's an interesting aspect of
science that I that I care about let's
say that's the only reason why I could I
could care about evolution